you have to understand in our election
system it's it's very difficult to
basically steal all the state elections
because you have state representatives
and it's very difficult but when it
comes down to Democrat strongholds like
uh Pennsylvania especially Philadelphia
um Atlanta when it comes to Georgia they
can swing the vote there they can steal
no one's ever going to stop them there
so the only way Republicans can actually
win votes is by landslides they have to
win by a landslide if it's a close vote
Democrats are going to steal it every
single time and next term is going to be
Obama's fourth term but Trump would have
won if it was a landslide right yes if
it was a landslide Trump would win 100%